what's up ramp Ledo we got another
episode yeah
before we get into that tour today is
coming up March 23rd can't watch it too
that's this Saturday with Jeff dock
jessimae Peluso Manny Martin Jew bar
fresh I think Brian Babylon is now added
to that line up so come through Kent
Washington outside Seattle then I'm in
Santa Cruz April 12th I'm in San Luis
Obispo April 14 San Luis Obispo April 14
April 15 for 16th I'll be in Phoenix on
a Monday and Tuesday and that's all I
got on the books for now y'all so we got
it advice episode coming up we hadn't
done one in a while it's fun to do
Brian Babylon on Tony trimco hosting we
answer a few questions some of them
would we're no questions I was wrestling
with the idea of edited some of the
weirdo questions out but I decided to
leave them in just so you can be
reminded how terrible society is so it's
a fun time
[Music]
there we go about that a pound no we
never lose me oh and vice vice versa
anyway you need the revised for your
mining don't big prize you can call us
and we will tell you what we know even
though we might be doing the wrong [ __ ]
in the own life
we give you outside perspective any
sounds right so we get in fights from a
podcast with some [ __ ] that
house should be giving it right but
eight all right
yeah advice that was a advice episode
and now the woman people give only give
advice they're getting advice from three
individuals yeah from all you know older
black man moderately famous movie star
art fashion music kind of sore okay I'll
take that thank you all our powers
combined because all our powers combined
I think we might we might put somebody
on the right path I think so I think so
so we got this we set up a voicemail
yeah quite easily quite easy was very
shut out the Gracie mm-hmm you know you
know why I like shout now Gracie why
because I know he's gonna hear it he has
to do all the stuff so he definitely
hears it so here freeze you know cuz
some people they might not get your
shout out shout out and you know what
shout outs make people feel good here's
the first piece of advice that we've
given the people shall shout shout out
the RUS building so he's definitely he's
looking yeah that's almost give him a
thumbs up
you know what shout out to this
Sacramento air B&B yeah ow
shut up we're you know we're here in a
Carmichael yeah right outside Sacramento
it's a little weird it got a gate you
know we have a weird gate that you got
to open to bring the car in but kind of
medieval but yeah in all of their babies
and travels first one tell them to have
to thrust to face in the bathroom gotta
be honest
[Music]
thank you cuz I'm so forgetful don't we
bring it back to fresh with me it's
instrumental cuz if I don't have my
toothbrush I gotta go buy one thank you
saving 3 to 4 bucks I don't possibly
toothbrushes over the years this [ __ ] is
out of control
I need two brushes and [ __ ] this [ __ ] is
terrible for myself cause I think about
the money
over the years a lot of times a bunch of
times could have feel that invested and
then I would have been Warren Buffett in
his prime goddamn - thank you
[Music]
you saved my future yeah
so many toothbrushes make into a shank
so many teeth brush make my breath stank
would they say today with the [ __ ]
toothbrush Malcolm brush my tongue and
my breath won't be so hot for the show I
can get them how my [ __ ] and flow to
save my children's future with that
toothbrush you saved my child's future
now I'd use that two bucks that three
bucks you don't get lunch mother [ __ ]
don't need no toothbrush cuz it too
frozen is with us yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I got three bucks plus
interest after 20 years it might be some
dough from that toothbrush savings that
you make it it will get some flow Hey
okay yeah so let's get into it
it's kinda say something real quick
before we get into this yeah I don't
mean the brag but that the move bars we
dropped had a lot of information in it
yeah I mean I was the first part I show
[Laughter]
a lot of information is responsibility
interests yeah how our money works how
maybe if you got an air baby some you
might do to help get some get your
rating pop it right that's all I'm
saying
you got that that's that's that's kind
of authentic podcasting and then bars
was just like if you go back and like
really get into it
you learn something yeah I mean you know
I was it was a bit of hyperbole on my
parts in I'll be Warren Buffett in his
prime if I didn't have to buy toothbrush
good there's a good point what is Warren
Buffett's prime is it this right now was
it like financially is right now I think
[Music]
all right let's listen to these calls I
was wondering how much weed is too much
weed to smoke on a daily basis because
I'm a college student and I don't want
it affecting my schoolwork is a gram two
months thank you handle you know you
know how much weed is too much so much
however much he had before I leave in
that voice man yeah listen no I mean
it's the gram I don't know man I don't
know you
yeah I don't know your tolerance I don't
know your how you function true after
that's it is for everybody it's a
different thing for me that [ __ ] is like
five milligrams as far as it's being
able to function and still be amongst
people like a five milligram maybe ten
milligram edible oh you will talk my
attaboy and he was talking about my
wee-wee
he's talking about weed I'm just talking
about me personally is five to ten and
then I can still kick it do stuff do a
show and not have the crowd think that
I'm really stoned hang out hey you know
being a good mood so I mean you got to
just figure out what that is for you and
obviously a lot of time the way you find
out that it isn't for you is when you go
past that a little bit so you probably
gonna have to push the limit and then
you okay that was that if that's not
about the dollar install yeah well Tyler
that's why Babylon smokes like five once
a day you smell five plus a day sure
[Laughter]
okay I mean I think for before we even
got started
yeah I mean that's because I'll tell you
this as your wheat older we sage young
man in college first of all if you can't
get your homework done
if you fall asleep you not getting [ __ ]
done kickback right and I'm saying I'm a
grown-ass man I lived my life you know
saying I fought Wars ok yeah but it
feels like I say smoke a joint
a little bit in the midday and there's
something at night
and they handle your business you can't
be a burner yeah don't turn it to a burn
don't be me well also I think if you are
a student and you you have probably some
tasks or some [ __ ] to do every day
it could just use smoking as your reward
for completing things let's use it just
as I got a smoke every day cuz I've been
listening to hello
Wiz Khalifa mixtapes yeah they'll do
that just smoke just say okay I'm out to
knock out five things use it you knock
out five tasks and say okay I'm just
five to one
that's your ratio you got to knock out
five tasks and then get blazed but
you're talking about a college student
so you got also you gotta factor in the
the financial part of it too you can't
just be spending all your money on we go
to school and you know you can't just
just you and now you just put in kind of
students into boxes of brokeness and
[ __ ] well yeah I mean I'm just relating
it to my college days I was broke and it
was a struggle yeah well obviously isn't
that wasn't he was like how much should
i smoke yeah cuz I smoked all of it man
I can smoke as much as I want and I have
access and I have money so just like
give me a limit I need to limit myself
he's it is sound like money was an issue
for this guy yeah that didn't that
wasn't it he's like I need discipline so
my advice would be to smoke that [ __ ]
smoke smoke but get your [ __ ] done or
get responsible fraggle stoners equal
Hannibal said I like the the the TAS
little to make it make it a reward yeah
or if you are gonna smoke before a test
fine
I don't know what state you're in but if
you're in a legal state then fine
a strain that helps you do [ __ ] you know
what I mean
helps you do [ __ ] and then one that
might help you slow or I like light
edibles shoutout to breeze mints
y'all ain't paid me none actually they
send me a little packets appreciate but
breeze mints
I like those three wanted they 5
milligram 5 milli and on the back of the
package they get a little graph for for
how your uh your high is gonna be oh so
they say they get [ __ ] they say time and
effect and they got a little little
thing to just show you and it's a
recommended one to novice 3 for average
5 is heavy yes
1/2 of 1 Percy yeah is so yeah so this
is just straight for his small dose yeah
and is is is breezy I mean that was
cheesy
[Applause]
[Music]
I want to come back from Cali or
whatever or Nevada or Washington always
make sure to grab a bunch of uh
breathing edibles and stuff and my mom
sorry my for snitching on you well you
know is with you
moms and adults it's a different tear
when you talk about mints versus a joint
it's not as the stigma is not there I
mean a joint is like you know because my
mom is the most nerd and I convinced her
to take a minute to take a minute it's
just a little different me I guess it's
not smoking she started just to find out
why this is not for your lungs and blah
blah blah yeah
so I guess it is medicinal and ended the
day and she justify dated her nerdy self
well she is she's never drank or smoked
swears nothing
that's unfortunate that people have to
even do those mental gymnastics to
justify it take it she did a weed meant
a weed man and she did it and she's the
nerdiest out but Babylon yeah white
blunts man I hope we're back to that out
you know what I'm gonna be I'm gonna be
totally honest with it it's it's one of
the one of my worst things that I do one
of my horrible habits that is kink is it
sort of like a being a fancy cigarette
smoker yeah it's sort of like you know
this is my smoke cigarettes but they're
not cigarettes is just very elaborate
fancy cigarettes and like I'd take boxes
of swishes to Europe yeah I talked about
this episode recently is that I that
that you know there's no Swisher's and
places I take boxes of like Swisher's
with me yeah let me just I've heard you
coughed before and you have a full-blown
smoker's cough and I've never smoked
cigarette sometimes and this is coming
from an ex-smoker
are you coughing as [ __ ] were you
confidence
sick Oh sick and then I was just [ __ ]
coffin [ __ ] I said oh my
Tony Trump coughed up a canary I'm still
but I'm like six seven months out now
yeah I'm still [ __ ] suffering from
smoke yep just don't get to see how you
feel yeah all right next question hi my
name is Ross I'm 21 years old big fan of
the show I saw you in Hattiesburg and I
was just wondering if you had any
particular advice or technique issues
like I have a hairy [ __ ] and I was
just wondering if there's like any
particular way that I feel like shave it
because like I want to try but I'm so
scared that I'm gonna cut my [ __ ]
does that make sense and if you if you
have any experience and manscaping or
you have any particular technique you'd
like please uh please let me know thanks
so much
well [ __ ] you okay first of all how much
hair is going out your ass first of all
raw is it is it is it wookie issue is
that a wookie level and if you're really
really concerned with that Google app
you know type that in Amazon rostro
patrolling mouse trouble there's on the
funny like that
I am i I was looking for something that
allowed me to wear skinny jeans and not
make my front bulge out so much right so
I googled dick girdle so I googled it
girdle and the first thing that came up
was this product on Amazon call Vicky Oh
dick
take your dick pic you're dead alright
so I clicked on it and it was a it was a
prosthetic thing where if you have a
skinny dick you put yourself
put your skinny dick inside of a
prosthetic that fattening it up around
your ball so it's like the push-up bra
equivalent for dick for dicks yeah sold
out I read the comments people like
horrible product didn't stay on to get
to run your balls you might get a two
pumps of then it snapped my homegirl I
was like yo I'll show her she's like
this is crazy say do you think imma
[ __ ] slip a thick yo dick on you and
you not know she's like hell now
wouldn't know that hold on they mean the
scenario let's say my [ __ ] brought you
you know you went to his crib y'all make
it out it's good he fingers you cou he
goes down on you okay okay he say excuse
me do you mind if I get a condom okay he
turns around he slips too thick your
dick on and a condom on top of that
comes back to each other little more and
then [ __ ] you would you know as a thick
your dick on she's like that's a me too
he's China he know he ain't got enough
to do what you need uh I thought that
was gentleman yeah she was being extreme
yeah it's like you can't say it's a meet
- if a girl takes her broth and it's a
padded bra he can't be like you had
bigger tits yet that's not nice and cool
the only reason I was here cuz Ross was
talking about the the hair thing is that
if you have a curious thing just google
it and there might be a product for it
yeah did you ever find that girdle no
all right so so yeah Sandler so wait
what it's called and I she's like I
think I talked to my sister about it and
she was laughs I feel stupid
they're called compression shorts and
it's what ice skaters and gymnasts wear
yeah to hold things down compression
shorts not big girdles you learning here
on the rampage next next Co next
question next con next color looks cold
next color looks cool next call mix cool
next I wanted to ask what are the best
YouTube compilations to watch on a rainy
day
as part of a fireplace for fun quality
question YouTube compilations that's a
good question yeah I do I get into some
YouTube deep dives you do probably and
in cumulative ly cumulative lovely
cumulative lovely cumulative cumulative
ly human all of my YouTube deep dives
have probably affected the productivity
and release schedule of this very
podcast through that well there was one
you did when we were in Africa that was
really interesting of athletes that got
caught up in crimes
oh yeah athletes that were yeah that was
a that was well that was an interesting
one yeah I actually when I was in Africa
I watched a couple
just different stand-ups and I was
watching videos on how to learn Nigerian
pidgin English okay and so then I
started getting more African content and
so then I watch this one about this cop
Amira she'd we talked about that and
just learning about the history Africa I
watch it I watch sports highlights
somehow I just watch uh every every now
and then probably once a year I'll just
watch
DX entrances from WWE okay just because
they had different ways that they would
come through true I watch yeah best
interest Shawn Michaels entrances or NWO
interest is for wrestling in be a [ __ ]
best uh just different highlights
bloopers oh just the lip-syncing [ __ ] is
always great that lives Seca but when I
do voiceover folk a football player
funny and then they just say some other
stuff no that's just classic humor yeah
but just done well bad lip reading is
bad lip reading that stuff on there I
was a rainy day doe specifically for a
rainy day if you if you would a chick
I'm gonna tell you what works or you
know let's make a gender neutral V with
a significant other
we cool here the rambling puppies puppy
compilations are oddly I don't even [ __ ]
with dog like that but I love puppies
puppy compilations are amazing yeah they
really are
puppy cook I love puppies are amazing
yeah
puppies are very very made they make you
feel good on a rainy day on a rainy day
a puppies will make you feel solid
advice Bam Bam we all make you feel good
up some puppy compilation yeah here's
enough i watch this youtube series
called new father chronicles what is
that it's this guy and he has two
daughters now and he does different
videos with the daughters but the the
younger ones is always the asian
it was black okay and then he'll he'll
just put in words for he'll put in
subtitles for what the baby that's
saying nothing is really saying that's
funny it'll be his he's one of the best
editors I've seen on YouTube so he's
doing pretty much of a modern version of
that movie that John Travolta was in
like look who's talking pretty but he's
doing it like he's doing it like
situation with but then now you know the
older one is actually talking so it's
interesting to see how he just interacts
with them and and is he a stay-at-home
dad with time on his hands uh I mean I
think that's the job yes there's a show
cuz they have some sponsors you know
they'd be having pretty big sponsors
like detergent and [ __ ] and he didn't
pay and he'll do a whole video it'll be
a sponsored video but it will seem like
one in his regular video then you don't
even realize to the end but it was a
detergent at all right you did that bro
I'm not buying any detergent but you
gotta respect that because it was smooth
it wasn't ham-handed
advertise it it was just it was kind of
still in the voice you have his show and
followed the same kind of patterns but
then you know they didn't feel like he
was getting guy nah you didn't feel it
didn't anyway it wasn't his style though
I forget what his name is but check out
new father Chronicles on YouTube you
showed me didn't you show me one from
Singapore ters dude who was like a
stay-at-home dad uh no that was Korea
Korea Korea reality TV the return of
Superman I was watching that on my
flight back when I was leaving when I
came back from Thailand in late July or
early August
my flight connected through Seoul so I
was like Korea air Seoul to Chicago or
whatever and so I was just you know it's
a long-ass flight so I just ended up
awesome I'm like what is this and then I
just click on it [ __ ] and this guy it's
a few different families they follow but
they had twins this one and so it was
just really
goofy-ass just production what is
reality TV but each each thing that
happens they have like a thought bubble
at Boeing and subtitle and it's nothing
it's like nothing left to chance there's
no you thinking for you it's just hella
just there's a lot going on just so much
going on we were watching it hi is it's
like almost soothing if you watch it hi
cuz it's so much action go what the hell
is return of Superman it's Korean
reality I'm saying like what is it Lord
but has a lot of some family it was
Superman though yes yes okay has nothing
to do it's super nice just different
families and just this they do boring
stuff with their kids but then the
production is is bananas for reality
show like you can watch that [ __ ] and
just zone out boy
you yeah you can't really read I don't
recover in but they have it in English
too they have the size of English yeah
cuz you know I didn't I didn't realize
that and I was about to pull out my
phone see like freeze a frame and put my
little Google thing up yeah translate
and that's like I just couldn't
understand yeah you got a Korean buddy
right here who can read it yeah well you
were there alright so yeah man what
about you Tony what's your youtube [ __ ]
uh my populations here's the thing I use
latency heaps specified compilations but
he could take you know be like oh my
[ __ ] is just you know I use my youtube
more as like a tool to find videos from
my from my set so my [ __ ] is like mostly
like 80s movies and just weird clips and
just strange [ __ ] like there's I try to
find a straight I go into these really
strange wormholes where I'm just trying
to find the weirdest footage of and then
a lot of B movies you know like that
Megaforce movie yes scene where he's
taking off on the motorcycle
[ __ ] like that yeah a lot of just like
terrible B movies I'm gonna tell you
what it's funny to is old
instructional videos like the old ones
for like working at McDonald's and yeah
these
well dude you ever see those creepy
Japanese McDonald's ads you guys know
I'm talking about oh look look up creepy
Japanese McDonald's ads and it's
literally like it's like Ronald McDonald
like hiding under a bed and then it just
shows the arch and it was like do not do
like the rain you did there's like five
or six of them out there and from what I
hear from what I heard they were actual
real commercials like they just made
them creepy on purpose and every single
one it's like there's one we're like
Ronald McDonald's like sitting by
himself like in a dark room but they
like suit this lady's just chillin and
then they zoom out and then you could
see him like hiding in the shadows
uh-huh like it's just [ __ ] I was I
couldn't I don't even use that for my
set because it's too creepy
dang yeah and yeah the voices actually
they they make it all like no you gotta
see the [ __ ] anyways yeah check that out
check that also I got a YouTube gaming
channel starting up so I'm not to get
into the gaming world tell me about that
it's just about to start you know I like
to play video games and I'm just about
to record myself doing that [ __ ] twitch
that [ __ ] I mean those kids man hits
watch people play games
what's your game I'm a 2k guy okay just
I got the NHL uh twenty Oh No NHL
nineteen
come on actually me and Percy was
playing that [ __ ] took the penalties off
and it was wow intense though there's no
penalties hockey
just slamming peaches yes yeah you have
to pass that puck hey no yeah you can
well with the penalties off is no the
fights don't really start because
getting knocked out but you can't you
can't fight on the game so like you when
you actually start scuffling can you
like it's like a you know like the molds
I hockey games are you going to fight
and yes you have an energy bar you fight
down there and then the team gets a
boost and stuff yeah oh that's crazy
do you think do you think they that the
fights will start simmering down a
hockey now that more black people
playing it uh that's a great that was
that was a thing like you know you know
white boys fighting on ice is okay but
they couldn't have like they would never
let that happen any be a yeah and I
always wondered like how these guys are
just [ __ ] pummeling each other how is
this part of this how is this part of
the sport I don't understand people they
just let me go yeah they let him go and
today fall down yeah range I'll give a
black dude who start if like if like a
Kimbo Slice [ __ ] got an NHL and then
he was just whooping white boys his ass
they would stop that yeah I think you
changed we would change the rule yeah I
agree
hockey is uh y'all been in a game before
yeah I've never been to hockey what
never I've never been to a black nope
what have been the one game I I would
put it as far as I play especially
playoff hockey I will put it over I will
put it over NBA shut your mouth at you
me at the event at the event okay enjoy
and I'm a huge basketball fan I'm just
talking about regular season NBA now TV
not playoff you have to be at the event
yeah at the event just the level of
intensity in this constant because NBA
has lulls man yeah it's like sort of
lulls and play where they especially you
talked about right after halftime third
quarters born it's for the beginning of
the third quarter dog when my father
still getting their seats from the
lounge or whatever so - goddamn front
couple roses that half empty and [ __ ]
and people come from eating this and so
and the tea
still warming back up so yeah it's sort
of these hearts right yeah
and so these cats like hockey they still
go heart the whole game you know what I
mean cuz for one you you probably get
hurt if you're not going that heart
that's weird I just I don't know maybe
we'll give valid points playoff hockey
versus NBA at the game no I'm talking
interview I think just I uh
last year the sports 2017-2018 so yeah I
went to more hockey games to NBA games
what team
I went to a bunch of Vegas go to nice
games Vegas golden night that was and it
was there in our and they wanted finally
what's the define rights as to how we
went to one or two playoff games and I
went to a Stanley Cup final game out
there know where they bloody hockey fan
they play it a t-mobile Arena in Vegas
that Mayor UNLV that not far from there
okay right next to the the park in GM is
the casino is directly what is it on the
strip man strip it's near the strip okay
that's the thing - you can bet and then
walk right into the stadium you bet the
casino next there my and then walk right
in and then after the game you go cash
out your bet that's night I guess
nowhere else can really offer that I
guess hot places that have hockey might
be cool like Phoenix I remember when I
was in college and when Atlanta got they
team and Ted Turner came to some game
and he was like crazy man they got a
hockey team there were the Atlanta
Thrashers
what is a I'll buy you one that's really
I mean pretty much as we were saying
we'll use it the crowd went crazy
billionaire vision yeah I'm gonna give
me a hockey team [ __ ] it that's great
[ __ ] alright I hope we uh we veered off
but we answer to
it was fun times next question
hey guys first and foremost I just
wanted to say thank you for coming to
sack last night you put on a great
[ __ ] show and I want to apologize on
behalf of Sacramento for that heckler
you know we don't we don't know her
that's not really how we do things but
but apparently you know someone brought
their drunk friends anyways my question
is I've been in this relationship for
maybe around nine months now and it
started off strictly beneficial and it
severely changed over the last few
months and I think one thing is that
she's she's kind of unwilling to go into
anything official but I think the main
hold up is the fact that she comes from
a very traditional Pakistani family so
the biggest thing is probably that
family aspect my question is since there
is kind of a huge not necessarily huge
but there is an age gap between us she's
about five years younger than me my
question is if if that's something based
on what you your guys's experiences if
that's something I should keep my foot
in the door on for it that's something
that you know you think she would you
know probably not budge on but I also
think it's something to do with maybe
maybe the age between us but anyways I
want to hear what you guys have to say
about that obviously we were pretty
serious about each other but there's
that one you know kind of basically
stumbling block that kind of keeps us
from going serious
but yeah instead of a sounding like a
bumbling idiot any longer I'll let you
guys go I appreciate you guys and thanks
for an awesome show
I know thank you I understand his
problem not because it sounds like I
mean what does he want does he want to
put a ring on him and she don't want it
I mean and what is being beneficial yeah
I think I was hoping up and then it
oh how this happen together you know
sorted together it sounds like yeah and
he wanted more he wants more he says is
the age gap so that is you having guys
faces you might though not at with her
it might not with her mindset it might
just judging off of his info he said is
a five-year gap he's trying to be
serious she's not off of that I'm
guessing she's between 23 to 25 22 to 25
yeah yeah I'm putting him around 29 30
yeah and so that's that's what I think
that is now also he said one thing that
it's very very important that we can't
miss is the the Pakistani family
component that might be so their
traditional traditional so she might
have something in the works that her
parents could be trying to push on her
you know if their quote unquote
traditional she's probably sucking its
second generation right if you're the
kid child of an immigrant right well
your first generation if your if the
child of an immigrant your first your
first generation so here's the thing
yeah being a first-generation
korean-american yeah I could speak for
like it's just Asian people Indian
people are like we have our weird quirks
and things yeah accidentally Pakistani
people whatever like we all have our
quirks and weird things and I could see
why he's concerned about that like for
instance my mom she wants me she's
always wanted me to marry Korean and I
because I I'd always ask her to teach me
how to make her kimchi or like these
good Korean dishes and she don't she
always gives me the same answer and it's
just like you want to learn you want to
know my recipe you marry Korean woman
and I teach her
she's a real [ __ ] Marisa she won't
teach me the recipes she's gonna copy
watchin from a recipe yeah cuz she's
like you if you want it marry a Korean
girl I'll teach her could you man cuz
you could you go on on somewhere and get
my quarrels actresses yeah I could turn
it into an elaborate thing yeah also
YouTube compilation yeah I don't know
cuz he didn't give us you say what
should he do should he give us he didn't
give us enough info he gave us a little
bit and he said a lot without saying
much we won't tell you what he did do
was that gave us a lot of positive
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
should I like you know not put all my
eggs on basket that means put my heart
out there to get crushed by this younger
Pakistani woman or should I go out there
and you know be ready to be ready to
jump [ __ ] well if it's not completely
serious do you need to be still when
your option isn't playing the field
yeah stay safe stay stay diligent stay
honest and just keep it going
you know why but and go it so good but
don't don't waste too much time
yeah have a sidepiece but uh let me go
to New York you got to have a side piece
if you're in that situation you got to
have a side piece you got it I mean that
doesn't that doesn't want to get serious
so you got to have a side piece you got
to have a girl you can another girl you
could go to so you could cut that energy
in half but here's my advice don't have
it be deep in Sacramento bro Sacramento
is too small to be a [ __ ] you all your
[ __ ] up and put on blast up with a
police yeah
oh yeah yeah I think I don't know I was
I knew more detail just about what their
exact convos have been mm-hmm and also
has he gave her ultimatum I was I mean
this is impossible but I wish I could
have just footage of her facial
expressions when he brought it to her
yeah if I have footage of those combos
and I knew how many combos there were
then I could tell you exactly yeah
that's a good you know what you know
like after like you 35:37 like we when
you get to this age and beyond like it's
just you've already seen it all yeah
you're just kind of like you could smell
that [ __ ] from the first conference
unless unless you know there's you know
none of us have been married but then
there's guys with it Mary really really
no you know that's when he really lived
with a woman didn't want you know that
but but till you get to that point you
can't until you put a ring on the - you
go - Jarrett's man and when tears ain't
paid us until you go to a jewelry store
and get that hardware you do what you do
[Music]
next question I'm uh I met it you know
true in my performances so I've had some
on camera farts check out my first
appearance on high maintenance the the
final shot I'm laying in a bit and
there's a fart that was real fart yeah
that was real fart you know timed it for
the camera really people don't know how
hard that is to get that cuz I'm like
this you don't know sometimes hard time
because sometimes do you feel the gas
bubbling and you cannot you know kind of
hold it off but you don't know how much
it's gonna clap oh it's gonna be if yeah
all right do you know say it could be a
mist
in Oregon a good fire don't care I fired
it during the take of a door tag I fired
it but everybody broke so they wasted to
take but I feel like it was a good take
with the fart yeah there's a couple
maybe and I'm trying to think about
farts farts bring joy to people like you
here yeah as much as everyone acts like
they hate farts like when they hear fart
they smile like yeah awful but we'll
deal with it ya know
farts are like capitalism you know
everybody likes it like it when one is
happening and you benefit from it but
then you see the results you like
what happened I don't support this but
you do look you know what I like to like
fart on an airplane and then get mad
that someone's farted me the whole time
like Jesus you know my new airplane bit
what did I do
[Laughter]
that's hilarious
I was I was like just like I was in a
terrible mood it was early as [ __ ]
that flight yeah when he did that [ __ ]
like it was it was just parties all
because everyone looked over at him like
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] up man yeah somebody
flies guys goddamn do sigh yeah you got
it was cracking up he thought it was
hilarious you gotta do it and that's uh
I got told y'all around the last time I
did it like three flights ago put it
nugge loud in first class again yeah
just a spice of flight up after Seoul
have a hole put it in and I'll just
drive it dropped it and before I was
walking to my seat just took a little
nut nut allowed weed it just dropped it
wrap it in the back you know in the
floor
smokebomb secrets a stink bomb stink
bombs away
did you like it's like it was a hidden
like where it was easily to know was in
my I had it like in this in my little
container so I pulled it out and had it
like kind of in my pocket while I was
walking up the earth
hey you know what in the hallway before
you get that way so I had it already out
and then when I got on a plane the
flight attendant was like hey hey so I
walked in I kind of threw it in that
back seat in first class on the floor
yeah and then just went to my seat came
back I was like I did that to this one
chick who's like a jerk and trying to
get to a connecting flight and she's
just like looking around being you know
you have some people on planes were just
[ __ ] mm-hmm and I put a nug allowed
in her little tote bag tote bag and I
saw it but she's like looking for a
phone gun on it so I go to the bottom I
always up in that nug was like I saw
like on like her book or whatever when
she went to get our foam it is feel like
to the bottom there's so much [ __ ] like
you have to dump that
out - right that is hilarious this does
amazing Babylon weed prankster yeah that
should be that should be emerged you
gotta have we prankster something like
that Frank yeah prankster
Scott Scott bomb bomb ledge up Langston
scum prankster on a flight because I got
to be on the path off the airplane part
has the plant plane plane plane wheat
plane we dropped dropped wheat as I we
dry wheat in the first class job oh so
fast stinking up the plane real fast
who's smoking we on this flight it might
be you in to see first class that old
lady with the bad eyes their container
open and it's in her purse so that's
that one where we got out of that dumb
fart question yeah question okay so you
guys want to move on to the next one
yeah okay next question
hey yo this won't be for all the guys
with [ __ ] be hesitation to suck their
dick and [ __ ]
amen if she ever be telling you maybe
when you're lucky or some [ __ ] here's
what you do as she's sucking your dick
you pull that [ __ ] out and you come you
come on an Eightball
you feel that [ __ ] a thought a face
you say how about that for love [ __ ]
this be me uncomfortable
wait we all have mothers and sisters you
son of a [ __ ] she said 8-ball yeah I
don't know what that man did it mean
that a ball or a I just imagine like a
Juggalo with like Eminem posters on his
wall what is 8 ball with you mean the 8
ball like the a bar hole or the eight
ball eight ball Coco I energy on this
guy's dumbass
vice vice the next question yo what's up
animal
big fan I just want my only question was
how long you have to date before you can
bust a nut in her with it being okay
because I'm kind of law I don't at a
loss in a crossroads right now anyways I
think now this is too full is it is is
it is it first of all when she gets an
IUD or on the pill yeah number one
number two
you clearly are you are you already
having I'm proud of my sex yeah yeah
yeah so when is it okay to bus one in is
if she asked nicely and she's on birth
control you as if she answers nicely
Afghan to ask yeah not a ton that's
gonna be the guy ask it cannot come in
you if she says he's comin II didn't do
it then do it but that's a simple that's
a simple answer just ask and you shall
receive
I'll be honest with you we live in the
[ __ ] future where even if there's no
birth control and you guys are at that
moment it's the first time you busted
nut you could plant B the [ __ ] out on
that you don't saying the holes yeah I
mean like not every time I'm saying this
is the first this is the first nut being
busted do you ever see that [ __ ] that
crazy [ __ ] that girls have the package
little there's like a little sliver that
goes inside their arm yeah do you know
I'm talking about the birth control
thing it's a pH controlled thing that
[ __ ] is crazy because they say it's more
effective than the pill yeah but it
misses your your your menstrual cycle up
and I just don't believe in those yeah I
don't know much about that technology
but know talk to your doctor have your
girl talk to your doctor about that
discussion with you and
yeah you got me actually that may be we
got to get a call let's get it to see if
there's a call from some women on there
I'm insulted okay next question
hey handsome Rambler I don't know where
I'm calling but I saw Hannibal Buress
tweet thought this is a podcast giving
advice so my question is what is the
what are the prospects for a single
black woman over 35 in San Francisco
thanks for any advice single black
married and have okay yeah that's a hard
one well I mean yeah I don't
yeah first of all you'd understand 35
that we talked about this time and time
again the mathematics are sort of skewed
for the guys that you probably would
have married when you were 24 25 are not
on the table so if you're a black female
please be open to dating house out of
your race number one number two I don't
know about your physical appearance or
whatever I'm not saying if you're ugly
or big whatever whatever you are believe
in it and have confidence number two
number three just get out there and
mathematically at least date as much as
you can because many people's you can
and be open to different individuals and
be open to at this point at 35 you are
an older man sketch yeah and
and if you're not messing with us dating
apps you should
yeah and expand your net in a few if
you're 40 you're 35 you should be open
to dating a guy who's 43 and divorced
with two kids that's probably where
you're gonna end up because the people
that you are that your are your age
aren't available wait a minute wait a
minute okay let's give this woman some
hope I guess it would be hard to date in
San Francisco event is it's a transient
ass city and people are always moving in
and out and now it's like he was black
and she's black
yeah I'm in New York Oakland tried
dating in Oakland instead also
sweetheart be open to dating if you're
looking for a black man a lot of
professional black women just don't have
it in a mincer that they can date a guy
who's a blue-collar guy like yeah here's
a guy who's like you know a plumber or
an electrician but this guy this guy
could probably fix everything in your
crib any quality the pipes leaking I got
you the electricity is out I got you
yeah he's probably nice and yeah you
never know you might be a plumber or
something who has like an artsy side go
to a silent disco good job yeah silent
parties cuz then you can kind of get a
gauge on people for real for real it's
quiet mm-hmm yeah and and it's a bunch
of people and it's no kind of because
people do got the headphones on so you
just walk up to them say what up yeah so
it's 35 San Francisco I don't know much
about the San Francisco they didn't see
but ii think the thing she says they
pull up to me she was like where does a
black female 35 5 yeah that's very
specific so on and so were you're saying
like ideally she would say hey is there
a magical 34 or 37 year old black man
who's single who got it going on and I
can just baby
I never comment up but yeah I would
because she lives in San Francisco
that she's got a diverse she's got a
diverse palette for true for a mate so I
would say yeah just you know keep trying
and he'll turn up that sounds horrible
how much should be a little bit more
proactive the handsome rambling wants
you to be aggressive yeah I want you to
have like okay get into pro like you
like you gave that guy that detail five
items
you know I'm saying I need you to go on
X amount of dates break it down what do
they do
where are they at you know I'm saying
speed try speed dating and be
comfortable with you know on your own
sexuality do it safe and have fun is she
is she going up to cats and hollering
cuz you know what my father's might not
be even going up in approaching my age
of not trying to you know so I'm saying
this just be have your ears open to it a
lot of times people don't be aware that
someone could be how lady to shut things
down just be more available to even
accept the approachable approachable I
got a lot of women unapproachable
they're like [ __ ] we got it this be
hey hey cool because a lot of times you
realize the chicks it I've kicked it
with started off with some cool chick
and we hung out we [ __ ] a few times
like yeah she does sound she sound very
sound very nice yeah or you can you know
use this opportunity to do some social
experiments here's an idea for one you
put up a tender or a bubble profile in
that profile you say I'm just here to
foot you see that's gonna get you a
certain type of guy well but you might
get some messages to say hey hey lady
you do more than that and then he might
be bullshitting but you filter out those
he filter through nose I'm the saying I
wouldn't say say [ __ ] you know what say
say hey I'm here to yeah I'm here to
have a good time
yeah good time yeah let's cut the
[ __ ] I'm cool you're cool what's up
yeah I saw that Mike what are you about
Annie you're cute I'm listening
yeah and I hang out with you and you not
whack and the sex is cool I'm gonna call
you again and then before you know it
who knows and also put it by
non-monogamous poly I don't do that you
don't do that either one I'm here to
have fun see what happens you know so I
hope you enjoyed this hodgepodge of
advice silent disco she probably thinks
she works in the tech world probably you
know if I was a CIA male analyst and I
heard her voice I had to make a call I
feel that she could be in even and if
she's in the tech field she might be in
the finance department okay they come to
get me I've said it's an idiot you know
they because I've seen your face coming
to benefit on bars out next question
[Music]
next question I don't really honestly
five and I don't really know what I'm
doing yet with my life great how do you
figure out what is you're seeing that
you're passionate about or what you
should do with your life
no I just figured that ask have a nice
day you figure out what you know try to
figure out what to do with your life is
yeah that's what religious yeah that's
limit and uh just noted what you end up
liking you might like something for the
next 5-10 years you might not like that
foot the whole time so just find
something that you know you enjoy and it
doesn't necessarily have to be and won't
be actually you know correctly it won't
be your full-time just have at first but
it's good to try some things in your
downtime and off time that you have fun
doing and make you happy now here's a
question all right because when she says
passionate that's a real that's a very
different thing from just enjoying
something like when you're passionate
about something that's all you think
about it's almost like an obsessive kind
of a vibe you know what I'm saying so
she specifically asking how do you find
that passion like you know what I'm
saying like I feel like when it comes to
passion as cliche as it is you know what
they say find a job that you love and it
feels like yada yada like I think she's
looking for that well here's my here's
my meager two cents as the eldest person
on this conversation right now
okay I would say first of all young lady
you're 25 so you have you got time you
have 55 yeah like ocean did do some
quick so you got some time I would say
first of all you have to feed yourself
have shelter live your life so you have
to find something that fills a financial
situation so you can live and then you
have 24 hours a day that other time
figure out what you like to do and if
it's possible to do if it is something
the arts if it's you might get into real
estate you might get into flipping
buildings who knows what it is just
figure it out but no you have time
enough to pull that off but you still
have to live your life you not gonna say
oh I'm gonna be a painter and get paid
for it or singer hey for it yeah I think
from the sounds of it she sounds
probably has a job or whatever and but
yeah I think you just have to try stuff
until you have a lot of fun and then try
to figure that out you do have a
nine-to-five put aside some time like
you said the try ship try Santana in
this is the future which is great versus
someone's asking to do this in 1954 when
it was no internet you couldn't learn
forever to learn [ __ ] you couldn't fly
anywhere travel meet some people you
know put some money towards travel put
some money towards yourself invest take
a salsa dancing lesson
learn a language get duolingo app shout
out the old lingo they don't give us no
money but do I started I started getting
on the Spanish on there yeah
not easy but easy what is I got a I got
a stay on it but it's it helps but but
yeah you you don't need to think about
you think about what you were doing when
you were a teenager or when you were a
child and what you truly enjoy because I
was thinking about that the other day
where when I was I think on my breaks
from college and maybe my senior year
high school me and my friend Dave and he
had a little beat machine and we would
just record goofy ass songs and that was
before I even did stand-up just sit
around and he would make a beat and I
would wrap and we record that [ __ ] on a
regular acetate wow what a scam no I cuz
it's the regular kind of yeah yeah yeah
and then and it was really just for us
and our friends anyway just play him it
was a really audience of maybe six tops
and and I have fun doing it and then
what is your name that's exactly what I
do now is just sit around and talk and I
understand this and this goes back to
what we said it this is not your 9 to 5
but this is something that you can go to
that it's not a comedy but it's another
outlet that you can still push your
creativity push it yeah who are and push
you want to do it you still learning
stuff you know I like the point that you
made about how they came full circle
because I feel the same things happened
to me because I went to school for
journalism and I never wrote articles
and [ __ ] when I got out of school I was
like whatever I always was a DJ when I
was since that since I've been in high
school and I you know I've always been
involved with music blah blah didn't
really know where it was going but now
it's like full circle for me too and
Psyche I feel passionate about the
podcast but it's funny because it's just
an amalgam
of everything that I just went through
in life so now it's like I'm making I'm
doing beats a lot I've always been a fan
of comedy and I'm interviewing people
like I'm a journalist you so everything
is coming you were on the red carpet in
[ __ ] Hollywood California that
was interviewing people and you were in
front of Entertainment Tonight so look
at full circle all day yeah no so that's
a great point you made a Hannibal cuz
sometimes you don't really know what
your passion is until it all just kind
of life just kind of gives it to you and
it all circles back around you're like
oh [ __ ] I'm living the dream
and also this also this you know people
who whine about I don't do this like
show me seven times or five times as you
fail to do something yeah never be
afraid to fail I could never you tons of
times just take an ale up to a laughter
lol soon you don't win that's what
Michael Jordan said hey I've had a lot
of game-winning shots but I've missed
more shots and I made so you guys don't
you don't and those and don't be afraid
to get don't be afraid and like coward
away if life kicks you in the teeth
sometimes it happens and you just gotta
get back up and try something else or
try it again or whatever and those sort
of smells character you can kick on the
team know what we fall down to get right
up oh yeah Search Search music we fall
down fall down get right up you know
what can I say we the the questions from
the women got so much work me so much
gourmet oh you know what they say or
make they read what you said they like
hey we are doing an advice show call us
and we'll do advice not talk good dumb
[ __ ] these woman who were me call for
advice about a topic I am 35 you know
I'm trying to figure out today
my passion do save my [ __ ] dog you
guys need to get in touch with your
sensitive sides okay and take this [ __ ]
serious because this is a serious
podcast and we're trying to save lives
yeah come with that [ __ ] [ __ ] alright
next one that it last one yes one next
question oh I was loosing me at your
array show and so I have two questions
one how does one get the next level fan
experience and two since you all travel
a lot how do you maintain long-distance
friendship I picked up something a lot
of young people are just starting out in
the de creus members what are your tips
and tricks for maintaining support and
friendship across a lot of traveling
solid question can you take the first
one how connects one the next level
she's talking about no I think she says
next level fan experience she's talking
about just you know buy merchandise on
the website around we're coming to the
show
Hannibal Burres calm oh that's last door
in the store there's some shirts hoodies
those call Chuck sees this little Jewish
word for like trinkets no trinket
tattoos just some shirts long sleeves
booties yeah oh yeah we got some hoodies
some mood okay some personal friends and
some goodies nice got a smoothies
smoothies yes yes
I'm good yeah all this type of stuff we
pay for damages hell yes blue apron yes
movies I get it we got hats rags
yeah goddamn cameras phones and bags
okay we got headphones beat machines and
microphones
we got bottom and some cyclones we all
just at the shop we got pay walls and
doors cars and floors clocks blinds all
that TV good times all that we got
chairs
we got rooks will sell cats
we got bugs we got shrubs all that we
got everything but no drugs no we got
mirrors we got we got mirrors we got
sila phones all that we got cryo we got
all that so yeah that's what we have it
to set and then it's in this you if she
wears that she walks around people ask
her about that she gives her
interpretation of what the Hannibal
Burns experience is about then you sort
of like nice laughing his next level
because you are like sort of like
transmitting your flow of Hannibal
Burres to another person and then a pass
of that energy can't go on and then
before you know it the world a better
place
absolutely there you go before you know
right in the gospel before you know it
that energy transmits to Hannibal Burres
male friends to call the number and that
leave dumbass [ __ ] questions
they a bit early today oh yeah so she
said how to maintain yeah yeah yeah with
a lot of travel yes it's tough it is is
tough because you miss a lot of
important events for people I always say
this one thing Hannibal Burres this is
back when I had a radio show in Chicago
you came on we interviewed you with me
and Molly Adams and Hannibal Buress said
that he has only been to two weddings
it's three now three I've never
forget that I was like what is that I've
only been at three weddings that's was
my sister's yeah I think it only been
one at that point yeah and I've been to
and I went to Jean Grey's way she got
married and quietly got married say I
will go to Jean Grey's wedding cuz I see
why she would have a good wedding most
weddings I just don't like because it's
like starts at the church and then you
got a city Mass and [ __ ] like if you
just have a good why can't mo if I could
just have a party I just caught why do I
gotta wear the tux why I got to do all
that like I just
just throw a [ __ ] party and let's
kick it yes sober wedding I wasn't it
was a little annoying being it's so
great yeah but uh but yeah I still enjoy
myself eventually I think that's when
you want to be the drunk this is at a
reception yeah it is tough with the
travel in China even with face time with
just someone maintaining friendships
yeah yeah because you've gone a bunch so
then I know now when I'm when I'm back
in the shower which is neither I just
try to I try to do things to kind of
just have a little events to have a
bunch of people together the same no
because it's tough to try to let's have
lunch you yes you let's let's meet up
here let's have some drink and let's go
to this spice that's tough so I yeah I
started doing top golf Sundays well also
another thing I noticed that you do is
that you bring your friends with you on
the road sometimes just to be like
handling merch or drivers you like that
I think that's a great way to catch up
with an old friend just be like hey
let's [ __ ] hop on a row for a few
days
yeah you know yeah bring uh yeah Big
Mike has rolled out with us cousin
Deonte Chee yes so yeah that's it I am
on the road
you got a Cana this is where I'm at yeah
you want to come with hop on
is so that's that's one way that I've
tried to me but it's still you know
still hard and is never gonna be perfect
idea
let's be honest I'm just hard to even
see people when you in the same city
yeah cuz that's true there's only so
many hours in a day and mothers our age
are already having families they got
kids it's like they don't got the time
either so you don't feel bad they don't
feel bad and you just kind of lose touch
but I mean honestly like like even
though I have a home base in Chicago I
feel like you know being on the road so
much too it's like it's you see you just
kind of like people stop checking in on
you yeah you know I'm saying they did
they stopped texting you mean like what
are you up to tonight like I don't get
those text messages anymore yeah
[ __ ] don't even know when I'm
home or not any right so it's crazy so
it's like yeah like it's really hard yes
I'm back in Ashe I'm like [ __ ] who do I
head up what's going on yeah strange
right feeling like a stranger in your
own city do you think social media helps
keep people cuz I think sometimes people
also happy that's the reverse no cuz I
feel sometimes people feel like for me
people feel like oh I know what you're
up to because I see it yeah you can say
that that's why I say it makes it worse
because they feel like they don't have
to like hit you up and catch up with you
because they just saw you on social
media and they know that you're alive
yeah it's like you know like normally
back in the days when we didn't have
that [ __ ] he was like you call him on
the phone Brian how you been what's
going on what's good with you let's get
up tonight that got that little what 30
minute conversation wouldn't be is the
same as seeing images of I rather see
some my images oh yeah I see it my
nieces and nephews get posted versus me
calling once every two weeks just to
hear a voice I get that part but I don't
know yeah I get that part but I feel
like it at the same time there's just an
excuse to not keep in touch with people
you know reason though the future is
gonna come when we will be able to send
Holograms out yeah papa
your wife is from me that's like I think
five five years ten years tops you know
what I think I think that we're gonna
figure out how to like upload all of our
[ __ ] memories and thoughts and [ __ ]
into the goddamn cloud before we do a
hologram think a hologram you transcend
yeah like a hologram technology to me
seems like it's gonna be our cake and I
feel like it's gonna get to a point
where there's not gonna we're not gonna
need more machines we're just gonna need
less machines and more gonna be more
like in the clouds yeah like we'll be
able to take all everything our whole
life experiences upload it and then you
could be just immortal not stay clouds
right now huh me here's my here's what
I'll say yeah if in six years okay
hologram FaceTime is technology isn't
mainstream and commercially accessible
yeah
I will move to Cambodia with three
months for three months even if I have a
family and I don't say Cambodia like
it's a bad place I'm just saying some
weird kind of remotes random random or
yeah I'll just move that's where that's
my bit that's what I believe six years
six years such what's the date starting
now today yeah starting starting Tuesday
January 29th 2019 yeah yes futures no
wait 2019 this 2019 so yeah it's six six
year 2025 only 25
yeah I'm gonna be 41 and you're saying
like what I shouldn't be doing that type
of frivolous stuff on a 41 my world I
made this weird-ass promise for no
reason just give me three months that's
it you can bring your friend
no you can stay
I have to go oh oh you have to take the
family with just chill back for a couple
months while daddy takes care of this
weird ass trip daddy gets lonely is
everything just a joke to you
Lissa maybe I'm a man of my word will be
a man of your word to your family yep
when you created these kids with me yep
we all right so yeah I probably won't do
it I take that back I ain't doing that
[ __ ] but I do believe in 25 it's tough
for full body for full body hologram
I mean maybe like a and like uh Mighty
Morphin Power Rangers head I mean I dude
who will give him instructions that guy
yeah what about you guys ever play that
video game from back in the day it was
like this weird like round white thing
and then like it was just a hologram it
was like sega made it no that [ __ ] blew
my mind when I first saw that anyway no
I swear to god bro that's a realist
brush you know what I'm talking about
it was like a round thing and it was
like a hologram that shot up that was a
fever dream Tony no it was a real thing
man it was a real thing technically can
you plug your phone into a projector
yeah I mean if somebody FaceTime you is
be objected onto the wall I have a
monopoly protect a projector in my
listen though there's there
is 3d projections you'd like this called
projection mapping so you could
literally take like a mannequin head
he said mainstream like I'm just saying
trying to get you to Cambodia
you can take a MANET you could do this
now the technology is there you take a
mannequin put it down and then project
person's image on there and it would
look like they're in the room we should
have guests actually here's a thing I
remember sitting Hannibal this text he's
like that might be too much Babylon was
it was dude who was running for like uh
either president in France and he did a
campaign rally yeah where he did a
hologram at three different cities all
together and it was like a campaign I
said do you should do this for your
special like a hologram special were you
at one location but it's live at
different cities he's like yeah this is
a bit much Babylon so you can it's
possible to get a full-blown wait when
transmit it to different places you guys
remember that whole thing about chief
keef doing a hologram somewhere cuz he
couldn't be in that city or [ __ ] yeah
that happened did that actually happened
I don't know if it happened but I
remember that right cuz he a couldn't go
there because he was banned he was
banned from some cities so he did a he
did a hologram Kaori she was supposed to
do a hologram concert was that Coachella
to park and that [ __ ] was a no that was
a disaster people talk so much [ __ ]
about that but didn't maybe I was high
you saw you saw a liar yeah was it dope
I mean I saw on the screen
oh and then I thought cause I kind of
saw up there like maybe that could be
were the people into it I I mean at that
point man I think people weren't
thinking it was whack it didn't look
like 8-bit yeah people were just
probably puzzled more right yeah I mean
what is I think you came up it looked
kind of real enough for people cool but
I think four years later it will look
wave a back yeah I saw footage of in the
[ __ ] look back to me I guarantee we'll
pull it up after this isn't look that
way all right all right
okay what's cheap whose is it so
hologram light let's work on that mm-hmm
let's work on have an order you get you
own a Cambodia
yeah yeah now it's also Hannibal and my
family together
Hey also sometimes I'm a liar but I like
high stakes yeah yeah let's try to have
hologram guests on the podcast first
podcast with the hologram guest who we
gonna have Christopher Guest yeah you
guessed it's Christopher Chris yeah next
guest is Ludacris next guest is Chris
which Chris is is Chris crispy cookie
Chris it's the cereal mascot
[Music]
[Music]